hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build with this week we're
just going to be doing a quick tutorial
on how to paint your nerf gun to make it
look like a cool sci-fi gun in the
future I'm gonna do in a more detailed
tutorial on how to customize and paint
some cheap toy guns or nerf guns or you
know some cheap guys you can find it
like goodwill and stuff like that this
is essentially the same thing it's kind
of an introductory I guess I got this at
a goodwill for about 3 bucks and I think
it's probably it's battery operator
something so I probably doesn't work
clip is missing but for my purposes it's
just fine because I'm probably going to
add a new clip or something like that to
it I'm going to change it up a little
bit I don't want it to look exactly like
a painted black painted nerf gun we'll
probably add some elements to it maybe
from other pieces of guns or something
and we're going to do a quick paint job
on it yeah so this won't be like a hero
prop this will be sort of like dressing
up your background characters it's not
going to be in a lot of close-ups or
under a lot of scrutiny you just need
some cool looking
sci-fi guns to dress up your background
characters with it's basically what this
is going to be we're just going to take
some cheap guns you can get at goodwill
paint it using some krylon colormaster
so I'm going to just spray paint we're
not going to do any airbrushing or
anything like that and like I said we
might add a few elements to it they kind
of make it look a little bit different
so it doesn't look like a nerf gun what
I'm going to start off doing is sanding
the whole thing down I'm going to
obviously sand off the nerf logo on
there and any of the raised leather
lettering and also there's kind of a
raised pattern on it that I want to I
want to sand that down smooth you don't
have to sand it if you don't want to I
mean if you want to get rid of the logo
and stuff like that I would recommend it
you can also put like a plate or
something like that over it to hide it
if you don't feel like standing the
whole thing down but if you do sand it
down it actually helps the paint stick
to it a lot better so that's what I'm
going to be doing I'm just going to be
sanding it down real quick
my palm sander and then we're going to
mask off some of the areas that we want
so the gray areas the thing I'm going to
keep gray and then I'm going to mask off
those areas paint the rest of it lie
flat black and then mask off some other
parts and I think we'll go with some
kind of a dark green or something for
some of the other elements to make it
look kind of military and then we're
weather it a bit using some cheap kind
of technique so let's get started
zero
all right so we got our base coat on it
and it's looking pretty good if you
wanted to you could probably step right
here and just do some highlights and
stuff like that on it to kind of weather
it a little bit but I want to add a
little bit of color to it just so it's
not all black so I'm going to mask off
some of the other elements of it and
then hit it with a I think like an olive
green or dark green kind of give it sort
of a military look I guess I also think
I want to add something to the end of it
the barrel to make it look a little bit
different I've got this barrel from
another cheap gun that I got at a
goodwill but by adding yeah one other
element to it will kind of give it a
different look or whatever just so that
right off the bat you don't recognize it
as a nerf gun in the background if you
add some other elements to it it can
take the skies a little bit so for this
piece I'm actually going to take the
screws out and take it in half because I
think I might add something to the
inside of the barrel it's kind of
hollowed out there but yeah
colors
Oh
so instead of dry brushing to give some
wear and tear to the gun and kind of
raise out some of those metallic
elements and stuff like that and make
the edges and stuff like that look worn
and used I'm not going to do any dry
brushing I'm just actually going to use
this metallic gray or metallic silver
sharpie marker you just highlight those
elements it's kind of a quick easy kind
of cleaner way to do it
zero zero
zero
Oh
all right so this is what we're left
with after a few hours of a quick paint
job and adding a few other elements to
it
the handle here is actually just from
airsoft gun that I had that was busted
so it actually slides down there really
nice the magazine is just your standard
magazine nerf magazine but I added this
middle box to the bottom of it to kind
of bulk it up a little bit and again
just again to give it a different look
and actually adds a little bit of weight
to it too so from a distance I think it
will pull off the illusion that it looks
like a cool sci-fi gun and like I said
in the future we will be doing another
tutorial on taking an actual toy gun or
nerf gun or squirt gun or something and
customizing it and painting it in detail
to really sell it as kind of a hero prop
if you're doing a movie or something
like that but again this is just a quick
how-to using some over-the-counter spray
paint and your gray sharpie marker and
you can make a pretty decent either
cosplay or a movie prop in a few hours
so yeah and like I said the gun itself
only cost me about three or four dollars
I think it was actually only three bucks
and then a couple cans of spray paint
and the barrel or whatever it was part
of another gun that was again only about
three or four dollars when I originally
purchased it I never spend more than
like four or five bucks tops for any of
these prop guns and stuff like that when
I go to Goodwill or to some kind of a
resale shop there's always like toy guns
and nerf guns and stuff there and
they're generally super cheap because
they're either busted or they're missing
parts or something
that works fine for my purposes because
I don't need them to shoot I just need
them to look like movie props so if
that's what you're looking for and
that's what's your goal if you need to
do it if you're doing an indie film or
if you're doing something low-budget
this is a really cheap way
you dress up your background carriers
and stuff or even your main characters
and give them some believable looking
props for very little money yeah I hope
you guys enjoyed this found it somewhat
entertaining and/or informative and hope
it inspires you guys to go out and build
and make some stuff of your own alright
guys well thanks so much again for
watching don't forget to look me up on
Facebook at James Jim J res and as
always you guys rock I'll see you next
time
you